RAE WANG: Ready?
Hi.
Good afternoon.
I am AUTHZ, also known
as authorization,
and this is my best buddy.
JASON COLLINS: Hi, I'm AUTHN,
also known as authentication.
I manage identities, your
users group sign in policies,
and directory sync.
RAE WANG: And I control
access management,
meaning who can do what
and which resources.
And together we're known as--
JASON COLLINS: I--
RAE WANG: AM.
All right.
Let's do our real
[? ring ?] show.
So, I am Rae Wang.
I'm a product manager on the
Google Cloud platform team.
JASON COLLINS: And I'm Jason
Collins, a Cloud deployment
engineer.
So we're here to
talk today about Iam,
how to do identity and access
management on Google Cloud
Platform.
So this is our agenda today.
I'm going to lay down some
foundational bits on identity.
It's a little bit dry.
The talk gets much better
when Rae gets back up on stage
to talk about access management
and some best practices.
And then the talk really
reaches a fever pitch
when we bring up a
couple of customers
who are doing some really
innovative things on Google
Cloud Platform with
security at scale.
OK so, on Google
Cloud Platform, we
want to make sure that
only specific users can
perform particular actions.
I'm going to tell you the
first half of that story.
I'm going to tell you about
identity management and user
authentication.
And then I'll give you a
quick demo of it as well.
So in the simplest
sense, you can
you just use Google accounts
to access the Google Cloud
Platform.
But the issue there
is that you don't
have any centralized
management over these accounts.
So for organizations,
it's a much better option
to use a Google
for Work-- the user
management-- to
create and manage
the accounts and credentials.
Now note, I'm just talking
about the Google for Work user
management aspects.
You don't have to use the
applications like Gmail Docs
and Calendar.
Though you can.
They're pretty awesome.
I recommend them.
So what this does
in particular is
it gives you a single
place to manage and control
your accounts.
And in particular, it
gives you an easy way
to suspend bad accounts quickly.
Because Google is
managing the login,
you get all the benefits and
security of the Google login
screen, and the password
reset mechanisms.
We have session and
device management tools
that help you know how
your users are accessing,
and where they're
logging in and when.
And we also detect
suspicious activity,
and we can configure
it to alert you.
OK, so this is a great
option for many companies.
It's the option I chose
as the CTO of a company
named Vendasta before
I joined Google.
Now on the other hand, many
of you probably already
have an identity system
that works great for you
and you're comfortable with.
In this case, you can
enable single sign on
or SSO between Google
and that identity system.
And you can continue using all
the practices and processes
that you have in place today.
With SSO configure, whenever
an unauthenticated user
is trying to access
the system, we'll
bounce the user over
to your ID system
to get credentials for them.
OK?
Now, the corresponding
user account
needs to exist in Google.
So we have to sync up the
user names between your system
and our system.
And to help with
this, Google as a tool
called GADS, or Google
Apps Directory Sync.
And what this tool does is it
syncs identities and groups
from your LDAP over to Google.
We'll talk a lot more about
groups in the second part
of this talk.
So Federated identity using
single sign on, using SSO,
is used today by large
organizations like Coca Cola
and Smart Technologies.
And I'll demo SSO for
you in a couple minutes.
To configure SSO, it's
really a simple process.
All you need to
provide are three links
into your existing
authentication system--
one for sign in,
one for sign out,
and one for change password.
And the change password
really could be anything,
because it's not actually
part of the off-flow.
Our SSO is built
on SAML 2, which
is a secure industry standard
protocol for exchanging user
assertions.
And assertions are just
basically facts about the user
that Google will trust.
To prevent tampering,
SAML allows the assertions
to be signed--
digitally signed--
so we can verify that the
information originated from you
and has not been tampered with.
If your identity system--
sorry, to allow that to work,
you have to provide one
more piece of configuration.
And that's the
digital certificate
that we'll use to
validate the signature.
If your identity system
today doesn't support SAML 2,
you can use third-party
identity management plug-ins,
like Ping and Octa and
others to bridge that gap.
So let's take a little bit of
a look at this SAML exchange.
There it is in all its glory.
Isn't it wonderful?
Hope you can read
this at the back.
I'd like to take some
time to go through each
of these lines in detail and
describe what's happening.
So let's start at the top.
All right.
I'm just kidding.
I really do like this stuff.
And if you want to talk
about it, come find me later.
We can tall.
But I'm not going to make
you sit through this.
I see some people kind of
turning for the doors, so--
Suffice to say, what
we do is we redirect
the user to your identity
system with a SAML request.
You authenticate the user
and redirect back to Google
with a signed SAML response, in
particular containing the user
name.
That user name identifies
the appropriate account.
On Google's side, we
create a user session,
and we grant the user access.
So in short, a whole
bunch of redirects.
And this is
typically transparent
if a user's already signed in.
There's some XML
goop, and a signature,
and, boom, the user's
logged into Google.
So I'd like to do
a demo of this.
Can we just flip to
the demo, please?
Great.
So a typical case would be
that a developer or DevOps
person wants to access the
Cloud console to do something
like start a VM or check
logs or a justifier firewall.
And so to do so, they point
the browser to the console.
So let me see if this
is going to work.
OK.
All right.
So they're headed
to the console.
Because the user is
not authenticated,
we're going to some
redirects happen.
OK, so first of all, we're
at this Google screen
asking for a user name.
You know what?
There's no password
here, because we
don't know if we need to
have a password or not.
In single sign
on, Google doesn't
have any the passwords or even
any of the password hashes.
So we have to ask
the user what domain
they want to authenticate to.
For example, if they enter
it @gmail.com domain,
we know that Google
controls the credentials
and has to be responsible
for gathering the login.
However the enter domain
that's configured for SSO--
I've set up weston-widgets.com
as an SSO-enabled domain.
Google will see that
and redirect the user
to the configured sign in link.
Great, it worked.
So here we are at my design
challenge login screen
for Weston Widgets.
And this is where you gather
the credentials for the user.
And you might do that, in
this case, through password.
Or maybe use facial recognition
or a chip implant or something
crazy like that.
jake@weston-widgets.com.
So when I authenticate,
this login system
is going to generate a SAML
response containing the user
name.
It will sign it with a
digital six certificate,
redirect the user
back to Google.
Google is going to
validate the signature.
It's going to look
at the user name.
It's going to find the
corresponding account,
create a user session,
and then redirect
the user to the Cloud console
where they are ultimately
headed.
So keep an eye on that URL
bar up-- the address bar--
and see these redirects
in action here.
All right.
We have made it to
the Cloud console.
And you can-- and
you can see that I'm
logged in as the user I intended
to be logged in as, Jake.
This same technique can work
anywhere you need an OAuth
access token as well.
So when you go to give
an OAuth access token,
the user has to grant that.
And so we need an
authenticated user.
So you flip into the OAuth flow.
And then, that will
flip into the Auth flow,
which will ultimately go through
the single sign in process.
So this same technique
works for the GCloud command
line interface-- the Cloud SDK.
It also works for any APIs
that use OAuth as well.
You'll notice that there
is a sign out link here.
And remember in
the configuration,
we had a sign out
configuration as well.
And so when I
click this, this is
going to sign me
out of both Google
and your on-premise system.
So if I go ahead and click that,
I've logged out of both systems
now.
So I've achieved
single sign out.
All right.
So one other quick demo here.
Google App Engine is
an excellent platform
as a service to easily
and quickly build
a line of business applications.
So for example, order
management, or customer support
systems, human resource
information systems,
things like that.
But how can we secure those
apps with your identity system?
With Google App Engine, this
is literally one line of code
away.
First of all, what
we want to do is
configure the App
Engine application
to be scoped to your domain.
So in case of Weston
Widgets, I can set it
up so that only Weston
Widgets users can have access
to the application.
Then in my app.YAML--
This is the wrong window.
This is the right
window-- all I need to do
is add one line of code.
Here's the single line of code.
That's actually a
line of configuration.
It says, login required.
I put that on my handler.
I save that and deploy that.
So imagine this is the intranet
app for Weston Widgets.
I will go to the intranet app.
And again, because
I'm not authenticated,
the login required
tells Google App Engine
that we need to kick the user
into the authentication flow.
Whoa.
That is not my app at all.
I've been hacked.
There we go.
I don't know what
I typed before.
So here I am at
the login screen.
Hey, did you notice
that we didn't
hit that Google screen that
asked for the user name,
like we did last time?
In this case, because the
App Engine application
I scoped to Weston
Widgets, Google already
knows where it has to send the
user to get the authentication
information.
So I can go ahead
and log in yet again.
And again, redirection
madness ensues.
And here I am at
my intranet app.
So you can see once again, I
am logged in as the right user.
And the Google App
Engine user API
makes this very easy to get
the user name from the user.
So there you have it.
To get single sign on configured
with Google Cloud Platform, all
you need is three links
into your existing identity
system and a
digital certificate,
and you're off to the races.
Piece of cake.
So now I'm going
to throw it over
to Rae for the much
cooler part of the talk.
Once we know who
the user is, how
we control what
they have access to?
And can you just flip
back to the slides please?
There you go Rae.
RAE WANG: OK.
Thank you Jason.
So now, your user has been
authenticated in the system.
The next thing we want to make
sure we can get them to do
is to get authorized to access
to right set of resources.
So let's talk about the AM
part of Iam access management,
meaning who can do what
and which resources?
The can do what part is
defined by an Iam role.
Now, when you think about
it, most of the time,
when you're trying to do
any meaningful operation,
it takes more than just
a single permission.
In this example, if you're
trying to get somebody
to be able to manage the
VM instances in a project,
they need to computer instances
to get, and create and delete
and start and stop and so on.
So we grouped these
permissions into an Iam role
to simplify your
management experience.
To grant the right
permissions to user,
you grant a user one or
more Iam roles resource.
So in this example here,
we're giving a group of users
the instance admin
role on Project A which
allows them to then go
and manage the GCEBM
instances in a project.
Now this is what
the API looks like.
To set an Iam policy, you
call the setIam policy method
and the resource where
you're setting the policy.
Since you already know
what the resource is,
the body of the policy contains
the other two parts in your Iam
equation-- the roles,
and then which members
you're granting each role to.
So as you can see in
this example here,
a member can be a number
of different things.
It can be a user, a
group, a service account,
which we're going
to talk about later,
as well as, if you want to share
with everybody in the domain,
you can just put a
domain name there.
And if you want to share
with the world-- say
you have a very public
storage bucket--
you can specify all
authenticated users.
You use the set method to
set the policy on resource,
get it back with the get method.
Standard stuff.
And then there's this method
called testIamPermissions.
And this is used
for you to check
if a user has the
permission to execute
a very specific operation.
And it comes very handy if
you're building your own custom
tool, your own
custom UI, and you
can decide whether to show
or hide a button for a user,
depending on what
permissions they have.
So these methods on a project
level have already GA'd.
So now you can use the API
to programmatically manage
the project permissions.
Now let's talk a little
bit about the roles.
If you're a current
GCP user, you probably
already have used one
of the three roles
on the project level--
owner, editor, and viewer.
Many of you have told
us that they're not
granular enough for
you to really lock down
your permissions, right?
So we know three is
obviously to few.
Let's try 23.
We're happy to announce
that we have just
launched over 20 new Iam
roles across of a set
of major services.
Let's look at some examples.
You often want to
allow your developers
to be able to access logs
so they can do debugging.
But you might want to expose the
rest of the production projects
to them.
And you can do so by granting
them the log viewer role,
so they can only
look at the logs.
If you have a CI or
CD system, and you
want to allow them to
automatically update
bits on GA and GCE,
you can grant them
and the [INAUDIBLE] deployer
role or the compute instance
Iaming role.
And that way, they can make
the update on the instances
without being able to
access data and storage.
You can use one of
the data flow roles
to give your data
scientists access
to interact with data flow
jobs without allowing them
to accidentally deleting the
VMs running underneath the data
flow.
And the common use case for GCS
is to allow a user or service
to upload data.
And you can lock down the
permissions in that case
by granting them the storage
object creator role, which
allows them to
create new objects,
but not have permission to
access or delete the existing
data in the storage bucket.
And you might say, wait, wait.
But there are a couple
of roles I really need,
and they're not on that list.
What are you going
to do for me, right?
I see a lot of nodding heads.
Well, our teams are
working very, very hard
on the next wave of
roles, as well as
giving you the ability to
eventually make your own custom
roles.
Now can we flip over
to the demo screen?
I'm going to show you how
these roles work for real.
So here I have a project where
I have the traditional owner
role, which means I can do just
about anything in the project.
I can look at compute and
storage and my API usage,
as well as billing data.
What I can also
do on a project is
to go over to the
Permissions tab
where I can see how many roles
I have assigned to which users.
As you can see, I have
a number of human users
who have the owner role.
And then I have a number
of service accounts
who have the editor role.
And to assign additional roles
to people, all I need to do
is to click this Add
Members button, which
brings up a dialogue.
I can type a user's
email address
and then select one of the
roles to assign to them.
Now let's come to the second
project, where I don't have
the owner, editor, viewer role.
And therefore, I shouldn't be
able to see most of information
here.
So the dashboard
is hidden from me
because I can't see the data.
I also can't access App
Engine or storage or billing.
However, I do have one role
on this project which is
to compute instant adding role.
So what this role allows me to
do is come to the compute page
and be able to see a list of
my VMs and control the VMs.
You can see the buttons, like
creating instance and instance
group, are available to
me because of that method
we talked about, test Iam
permission, checks that I
have permission to
execute these operations.
Can we go back to the slides?
Thank you.
All right.
Since Iam policies
are set on resources,
let's talk a little more about
how resources are defined.
Resources are not just
a random flat list
of VMs and GCS buckets.
They have relationships
with each other.
And we can use these
relationships to simplify
how you can manage policies.
If you're a current
user, you've already
used this concept
called a project.
A project is a basic container
of resources, and a trust unit.
The roles that we have just
seen the slides in the demo
can be assigned on
the project level.
And when you do that, they get
inherited by all the resources
underneath the project.
So for example,
what we just saw,
you assigned the instance
admin role to a set of users.
Then these users can
manage all the instances
within the project.
You don't have to go and
permission each individual VM
instance.
And when your out
of [? scaler ?]
spins up another
new instance, you
don't have to go and hurry up
and add a policy for your admin
to do their job.
They get us through inheritance.
Now some of the resources
underneath a project
can also be permissioned
individually-- for example,
pops up topics or GCS buckets.
And I know a lot
of you want to be
able to do that on other
types of resources,
especially VMs come
up a lot, right?
Our teams are working
hard to find a solution
to allow you to be
able to do that.
Some of you have been a
GCP user a for a while.
And you know as the
usage grows, you
might end up with a
large number of projects.
And then it can get a little
unwieldy to manage at scale.
And that's why we have
introduced now the organization
node.
The organization node is a layer
that sits above your projects.
It's a company's root node for
managing your GCP resources.
If you're a Google for Work
customer, when you enable
the organization node, then
from there on, whenever
any identity from your domain
goes and creates a new project,
whether it's a service account
or user, when you create
a project, the project
will automatically
belong to your
organization node.
So no more shadow
projects and rogue admins.
You have control of at all.
And there are a couple of
roles that we have specifically
designed for the
organization node.
One is the organization admin.
Just like what the name
says, it allows your admin
to have central
visibility and control
of all of the projects,
all of the resources
inside the company.
Another interesting role is
the project creator role.
So if you want to actually
control who in your company
can set up new projects
to create new resources,
you can use that role to
define that set of users.
Also, other roles that you saw
when we looked at the project
demo, they can also be granted
at the organization level.
And again, because of
the policy inheritance,
when they're granted
for the organization,
they get inherited by all the
projects and all the resources
inside the organization.
So if you have a
networking team,
you want to allow
your networking team
to manage all the
networks in your company,
you can grant them
the network admin role
on the organization
level, which will
allow them to manage
all the other networks,
and all of the projects
inside your company.
The organization node
is in alpha right now.
So if you're our current
Google for Work customer,
you can work with your account
manager or a sales partner
to have one enabled
for your company.
So let's take a look at a demo.
Switch over?
Thank you.
So here I have a company,
which I conveniently
named the Next Demo Company,
which has an organization node.
And once you have an
organization node,
you get an extra
drop down list, which
is called the
Organization picker,
where you can select to look at
things from your organization
perspective.
And when you do that, there
are two tabs available to you.
One is the Projects
tab, where you
get to see the entire list of
projects inside the company,
regardless of whether
you personally
have specific permission
that's printed on a project.
You get that
through inheritance.
And the second tab is
the Permissions tab,
where you can view and
manage permissions granted
on the organization level.
And here, you can see
many of the Iam roles
that we talked
about on the project
level can also be granted
on the organization level.
And the same dialogue
add members, again,
will allow you to grant
additional roles to people
on the org level.
So if we look under
Project Creator,
you can see that I've granted
this role to my entire domain,
which means everybody
in my company
can go and create new projects.
Switch back to the slides.
All right, so when we
previously told you
that we've already told you
everything about identities,
that wasn't completely right.
Sorry, Jason.
There's still one
type of identity
that I want to talk
to you about here,
which is a service account.
Now a service account is not an
identity for your human beings,
like user groups.
But rather it's
the identity that
can be used by your
programs to authenticate
to access GCP APIs.
Your users can go to web
page like Jason just did,
and type a username
password and login.
Well, your program
isn't going to do that.
So instead, they
authenticate with keys.
One or more keys can be created
for each Iam service account.
And since keys basically give
you access to your resources,
they're very sensitive data.
You want to take
good care of them.
If your programs run on App
Engine or Compute Engine,
then you don't have to worry
about it because we manage
the keys for you
and we regularly
rotate the keys to
guard against leaking.
If you run a program
somewhere else,
you can download the keys
to be used in your own code.
But keep them safe.
But the curious thing
about service accounts
is that a service account can be
both an identity and a resource
in your Iam policy.
And this is why.
If you're using service
accounts for your VMs
to route to access
GCP APIs, your VMs
need permissions to
go to these APIs.
And that permission are granted
through the service account.
Right?
In that case, you're granting
Iam roles on certain resources
to the service account.
And the service account
is acting as an identity,
the identity of the VMs.
However, you also
want to make sure
that you can actually control
who has access to the service
accounts.
You don't want any random person
to be able to just bring up
a VM and use a service
account and then
they get access to
all your resources,
and all bets are off.
And that's not good.
So, you can actually
commission the service account.
For example, grant one or
more of your specific users
we need to be able to do
things with these VMs.
The service account
actor role to allow
them to assume the identity
of the service account.
Now in this case, in
this specific policy,
the service account
is the resource
that you want to permission.
Another feature that we
have launched recently
is per VM service account.
Now, why do you need that?
You need that so that your
different VMs and your project
can run with different identity.
And that gets different
sets of privileges.
So in this example
here, in your project A,
you have two components.
Component A needs to
manage and therefore
be the editor on Project
B, whereas component 2 just
needs to be a storage bucket.
You don't want to grant
your entire project's VMs
the superset of all
of these permissions.
Because that goes against
our security best practice.
So instead what you do, is
you have two different service
accounts representing these
two different components-- set
of VMs And grant each
service account just
a minimal set of privileges
that your VMs need
to use to operate.
You can also dynamically
change the privileges
granted to the service
accounts while the VMs are
running without having
to recreate our VMs
All right, so now
you know what you can
do with the new Iam features.
Let's go through some
security best practices
to talk about how to
secure environments.
First of all, principle
of least privilege.
This applies to all three
parts of your Iam policy.
The identities, the roles,
as well as the resources.
What not to do is to grant
everybody the owner role
on your entire organization.
I know we are good friends.
We want to share.
But this is risky, because
then any accidental mistake
or an intentional hack can
just bring down your app
or leak your data.
So instead, you want to be very
specific and very deliberate
in your policies.
For example, granting
your security admin group
A, the security admin role,
which allows them to change
SSL certs and firewall
rules on specific projects
that they need to work on.
Use groups.
Managing permissions
on individual users
can quickly get both
cumbersome and error-prone.
So you want to use groups.
Let's say you have
a SecOps team.
You want to create
a group for them.
So as new members come into
a company and join the team,
all you need to do is to
add them to the group,
and all of a sudden, they
have the same privileges
as the rest of their peers.
And you might want to assign
more than just single role
to the group.
It depends on the job function.
For example, here
your security team
might need a security admin
role to do the firewall SSL
[? source ?] change,
and allow the ORO just
to monitor what's going on.
And then as time goes on, their
job function might change,
and the set of Iam
roles might change.
And all you have to
do to stay up to date
is to change the set of
Iam roles granted to group.
Again, you won't
have to go and modify
that for each individual
users, and try
to keep them consistent.
The Iam policies
allow you to secure
who can access your resources.
But you also want
to safeguard who
can change these policies, which
is also granted through an Iam
permission, as well as who can
change user group membership.
Because either of those two
can allow additional people
to access your resources.
Another way to
safeguard your policies
is through audit logging.
Some of you might have gone to
the audit log session yesterday
and have heard that
we now have support
for audit log for project
level permission changes.
And we're going to be
adding it for other resource
levels in the next few months.
And if you use
service accounts, we
talk about how keys are
really sensitive data.
And you can guard
against leaking
by regularly rotating them.
And you can do so by
creating a new key
and updating a program
to use the new key
and then go remove the old key.
And all of these APIs, including
the API [INAUDIBLE] list
to create and manage
your service accounts
are part of the Iam API,
which is now in beta.
So we promised you this target's
going to keep getting better.
Now comes to the
most exciting part.
You're going to hear from a
couple of real GCP customers
on how they have used
the Iam features.
First we're going
to have SnapChat.
And as you know,
SnapChat rounds on GCP
and serves over
100 million users.
And without a private
user data SnapChat has,
it's no wonder that
they really care
about security and privacy.
So we have Subhash from
the SnapChat security team.
SUBHASH SANKURATRIPATI:
Thanks, Rae.
So for those of you that
don't know what SnapChat is,
we're a storytelling
social network.
We have a large number of users
that log in on a daily basis.
The current user
numbers are somewhere
upwards of 100 million-plus
daily users that actually
log in or interact with our
servers using our mobile apps,
viewing about eight-plus
billion videos.
And thanks in large part to the
Google Cloud and App Engine,
we're able to service that
large number of requests
with a very small
number of engineers.
We're about a 200-plus
engineering size team.
And the other part that
as a security engineer,
the other advantage that
the Cloud gives us is we're
largely responsible
for making sure
that the security of a project
or a cross-project interactions
are secure.
But we don't have
to really worry
about how the underlying
infrastructure is built.
That is Google's responsibility.
Effectively, what we
are responsible for
is understanding where the
Google security contract ends,
and pick it up from there.
And prior to the advent
of the organization node,
we had a very strict policy
on creating new projects.
Because A, anybody
could create a project,
and we wouldn't even know
that such a project existed.
So with the advent of
the organization node,
I think it will help us.
We'll probably have
a lot more projects.
And next, I'm going to
introduce a customer that
apparently has a
lot larger footprint
that what SnapChat does.
I'm going to introduce David
from the Google SecOps team.
DAVID "CACHE" MCWHERTER: Hi.
My name is David, and I work on
the Google's security ops team.
And basically, my
job is to make sure
that all of Google's usage of
GCP is secure and protected.
What most of you
might not know, is
that Google has
been for a while now
a fairly heavy
user of GCP itself.
We have over 100,000
GCP projects running out
in the wild already running
all sorts of interesting apps
from our HR tooling
to compensation
to internal incident
response management tools.
And Subhash, we even
have a social network.
I'm just saying.
Anyway.
There we go.
So Subhash and I, we're going
to talk to you a little bit
about how do we-- two things.
How we secure the
accesses within a project,
and the segment data
within a project.
And then also, how
to-- once you've
gotten to 100,000
projects, how do you
secure the 100,000
projects you have
to make sure they're
doing something sensible?
So one of the things that
we like to do at Google
is we like to make sure,
again, that everything
has as few privileges as it
needs to get its job done.
And so what that means
is, for Google, anyway,
is that typically services are
given access to sensitive data
and customer data.
But the engineers,
the developers
and reliability engineers don't
actually get any permissions
to the sensitive data.
Instead, they're given access
to manage the services.
And they can, if
they need, then go
access the data through
the services where
business logic to secure
and lock down access
can be done very specifically.
SUBHASH SANKURATRIPATI:
So I think as Rae already
mentioned, prior to
the advent of Iam,
there were pretty
much three roles.
Editor, viewer, and [INAUDIBLE].
And editor, viewer and owner.
So if a project has user
data, pretty much even
the least privileged
role of viewer
means nothing from a
security perspective.
Because once you're a
viewer, you pretty much
have access to the entire
data in the project, which
is a huge security risk for us.
So one can always do
some hacks by basically
revoking viewer access
to certain buckets
or to data sets.
But that still gets unwieldy.
So thanks to Iam, I think
in the last couple of weeks,
where it was the
floodgates were relieved,
and we could actually
start using Iam,
we've been able to significantly
reduce the number of developers
that actually have access to
these coarse-grained roles.
And as Rae already
mentioned, some
of the roles that help us
a lot is the log viewer,
because most times,
developers are actually
just trying to debug problems.
So they can use
the log viewer role
to get access to the logs, the
App Engine viewer role, which
gives them a quick snapshot and
the App Engine service admin
role which allows them
to do traffic splitting,
to run some
experiments, and also
change the version-- the
rollback versions in case there
are any issues.
And also, we are pretty excited
of what the future can hold.
Because with things like
the App Engine deployer,
we can change some
of our workflows.
And then once those
workflows are changed,
I think we have a-- we will
have a much larger reduction
in the number of developers
that actually have access
to these coarse-grained roles.
David?
DAVID "CACHE" MCWHERTER:
Thanks, Subhash.
Now, continuing with the
theme of locking down access
to resources, I wanted
to just talk to you
on the subject of
micro services,
especially within
GCE apps in GCP.
New with Iam, as Rae
mentioned, was the ability
to create multiple service
accounts on a single project.
And with this capability,
we can basically
let each of these
service accounts
represent one of
our micro services,
give it access to just
the data it needs,
and then spin up a fleet of VMs
associated with that service
account.
And basically do
that again and again,
making sure that
each service only
has access to what it needs.
Subhash, what do you
think about that?
SUBHASH SANKURATRIPATI:
So the possibilities
that this opens up is
pretty much endless.
So one of the cool
things you can
do with this is imagine
you have-- you're
trying to have two micro
services in a given project.
With the compute engine
service accounts of the past,
there is no way to
realistically segregate
the accesses that each of
those micro services has.
So you could always hack it up
by creating a different service
account, manually pushing
those service account
private public keys
to the entire fleet.
But then, like, anybody
that can log into that box
has access to the private key.
It gets pretty messy.
So imagine this scenario
we're talking about
like, Alice has her
own micro service.
Bob has his own micro service.
Only Alice can deploy code
to her micro service fleet.
And so Bob can deploy to his.
So the only persons that
can actually deploy to it
is the owners of
the service account.
What this allows you to do,
for example, each micro service
could have its own bootstrapping
secrets or its own encryption
keys or data encryption keys.
They're effectively tied down
to that compute engine service
account.
And only the owners
of that micro service
can actually deploy code to it.
You can actually take
it one step further,
where Alice and
Bob don't actually
have direct access to deploy.
They actually delegate
that authority
to a deployer service account,
which then has the authority
to deploy to the fleet of
micro service VM instances.
Which means the developers
don't actually have access
to the raw instances, but
they can always get to it
in case there's an emergency.
And this also opens up
the ability to do true
micro-service-to-micro-service
authentication.
Imagine you have these
two Compute Engine service
accounts.
Nobody but Google
has the private keys.
Of course, Google is trusted.
And given in that
paradigm, there
is nobody else that can
actually sign on that
or act on behalf of
that service account.
And when the server receives
it or the target receives it,
can actually vouch for it that
this is indeed this message
or GWT has indeed been signed
by the service account.
And there is an
independent way for me
to query that public key.
So you actually can do true
micro-service-to-micro-service
authentication without private
keys floating all around
the planet.
So I think this is
pretty compelling for us.
DAVID "CACHE" MCWHERTER: Amen.
And I think one
of the key aspects
there's like when I'm auditing
my engineer's source code,
I don't actually have
to care about what
they're doing with their
private keys anymore, right?
I don't have to make sure
they're deleting them,
rotating them.
Oh, my gosh.
Huge.
SUBHASH SANKURATRIPATI: So you
know what else could be cooler?
The nature or the
content of, as one knows,
everything that SnapChat
or any content that's
shared on SnapChat is FMRL.
So we figured, why not
take it to the next level
and say the developer
access to critical resources
is also FMRL?
And what if, in a steady state
nobody had access to anything?
DAVID "CACHE" MCWHERTER: What?
Are you feeling OK, Subhash?
SUBHASH SANKURATRIPATI:
Hear me out.
Rae gave us some
new functionality.
Let's see what it does for us.
DAVID "CACHE" MCWHERTER: OK.
SUBHASH SANKURATRIPATI: So we
basically built a ACL leasing
infrastructure.
So imagine you have an
access-controlled service that
has the ability to set an Iam
policy on a set of projects
or the entire organization.
Now what you could do
is, supposing an engineer
wants access to a
resource, the engineer can
go in to that service,
say, I will need access
to this resource,
specify a time,
and then that access-controlled
service can actually
go back and check
whether that engineer is
in the whitelisted set of users
for that particular resource
they're trying to access.
If yes, they're
given that access
for that short period of time.
And then automatically, and
when the duration of the lease
has expired,
basically the service
would do another set Iam
policy without that user.
And the resource,
and boom, the access
to that resource for
that developer is gone.
DAVID "CACHE" MCWHERTER: Crazy.
Only SnapChat would
invent temporary FMRL.
SUBHASH SANKURATRIPATI:
[INAUDIBLE].
DAVID "CACHE" MCWHERTER: So now
that we've solved the project--
Iam has solved the project--
there's the problem of project
level security, I
was hoping to move on
to talking about my favorite
topic, organizational level
security.
SUBHASH SANKURATRIPATI:
Hang on, hang on, hang on.
DAVID "CACHE"
MCWHERTER: What's that?
SUBHASH SANKURATRIPATI:
So Iam has
allowed us to significantly
improve our access control
posture.
But if you look at the
gamut of resources-- just go
to the developer
console and see there's
probably 25 different
kinds of resources.
We've gotten resource--
our roles, for, say,
about seven or eight
of them-- there's
a whole gamut of resources
for which we need roles for.
For example, BigQuery,
DataStore, TaskQueues.
There's a whole gamut
of them that Rae
will give us pretty soon.
She's still going
to be on my number
one favorites on
Google Hangouts.
And of course, we
need custom roles.
Because each organization
always has the need
for doing something special.
What if Google allowed us the
ability to say take this role,
but I don't like this
particular functionality.
So instead of a customer
being able to create
or having to create an
entire role from scratch,
just minor tweaks to it.
And the next thing that
we're also be able-- we
have implemented or hacked
together on our own,
because the DataStore
doesn't actually
have kind-level permissions or
namespace-level permissions.
So in the absence of
that, what we've done
is basically in
remote API, we're
parsing the proto buffs
as they're coming through.
We're constructing
these objects,
extract the namespace
and the kinds.
And then we're doing
ACLs on top of it.
So far from ideal, we would
love for Google to solve it.
And that's one
more thing that I'm
hoping Rae is going to
give us pretty soon.
DAVID "CACHE"
MCWHERTER: Good point.
Good point.
Thankfully, I'm
sure the Iam team
will be happy to know they'll
still have jobs next week.
SUBHASH SANKURATRIPATI:
There's one more thing.
Sorry.
So we've got enough
ex-Googlers in our company.
And any time we talk
anything about authentication
and authorization, they tell me
the super secure reverse proxy
that Google has that
apparently solves everything
on the planet-- I can't say the
name because they'll probably
kill me-- but let's call it
a secure reverse proxy that
can effectively perform
any authentication,
any authorization
decision, and force
additional levels
of authentication.
Hey, tap your UB key.
You haven't tapped it in
more than five minutes.
Tap it again.
This is a sensitive
resource, so I'm
hoping that Google's going to
deliver us that capability.
DAVID "CACHE"
MCWHERTER: I have it
on good authority that some
people are working on it.
These very problems, Subhash.
SUBHASH SANKURATRIPATI: Cool.
Thank you.
DAVID "CACHE" MARKETER: OK, so
now organizational security.
So at Google, we
have a basic theory
on organizational security
in that we don't really
want to get too
involved in managing--
micromanaging our engineers
in what they're doing.
We want to give them
generally free leash
to do what they need to do,
so long as it's reasonable.
And 99% of the time,
it's irrelevant to Google
security posture.
But sometimes, occasionally,
we get situations
where an application
needs to access
secure data, company-critical
data, or talk
to other services that are
fairly important to the company
as a whole.
And that's where my team
tends to get more involved.
From my perspective, I think one
of the biggest things that this
is basically rooted in is
understanding what's going
on inside the company from
like a 20,000-foot level.
And so the org node
policies that we can apply
will let us take
actually snapshots
of what's going on in all the
Google-owned GCP projects.
And that's like an
incredibly powerful tool.
Then after we know
what's going on,
then we can start
reasoning about it.
And then we can then
try to make sure
that only the right kinds
of things are happening,
either by talking
to the engineers who
are creating the projects
and using the projects,
or by actually going
in organizationally
and shutting things down
that shouldn't be done,
shouldn't be allowed.
And what's super important to
me-- I assume also to you--
is that I don't actually
get-- my team doesn't actually
need permission to go and
read any of the critical date
or sensitive of the company.
We really just want
to be able to get
a sense of what's
going on in the control
plane of the system.
SUBHASH SANKURATRIPATI:
Largely agree.
But I think the one
area, because we
have a lot of user
data in our projects.
Anytime a project has user data,
pretty much, the security team
kind of decides what they
need, because developers always
want access to everything.
So the security team will
say, hang on, not so much.
Let's tweak it.
DAVID "CACHE"
MCWHERTER: Identify
the nature of the
application and then
decide what security
policy should be applied.
Good point.
Thankfully, Iam was
designed with these kinds
of issues in mind.
And it allows us to do all
sorts of interesting things.
It allows my team to build
interesting tools to actually
try to manage our problems.
And so one of the things
that we've done at Google
is we've introduced an
onboarding workflow.
So when new projects are
created by our engineers,
we can actually discover
them by listening
at the organizational level.
And we can basically see who the
people are creating and using
the project, and we can
send them an email saying,
by the way, these are the
best practices for security,
and these are the expectations.
And this is how you register
for further security reviews,
if that's necessary.
This is how you
actually go and get
access to critical resources,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Another thing that we've
recently started doing
is doing a continuous scan
of all the virtual machines
and all the resources in
use, and actually sending
those teams a monthly reminder
indicating what they're
doing, what they're using.
And if there's
anything that looks
like it could be
terminated, like VMs that
could be shut down, we
give them the suggestion
to turn them off.
And the best-- most
secure VM is a dead VM.
If you ask me.
SUBHASH SANKURATRIPATI: So--
DAVID "CACHE" MCWHERTER:
What do you think?
SUBHASH SANKURATRIPATI:
I think it's
great we've pretty much
followed the same philosophy,
except in cases
where, of course,
as I said earlier,
project that use the data.
And one example I want
to give is recently,
there was that March 1
open SSL vulnerability
was going to be-- vulnerability
was going to be released.
So you're like, OK,
what is our footprint?
Prior to the
organization umbrella,
we would have no
way of knowing it.
Thankfully, Rae whitelisted us.
We were on the alpha program.
So we went, got assigned a
compute instance admin role
to a service account
team, made sure
that you're able
to get an accurate
inventory of every
virtual machine we owned.
And then populated the
keys also just to make sure
that in case it was Heartbleed.
Next, we had the ability
to quickly go and patch.
Thankfully, we didn't have to.
But the fact that
the org node existed
enabled us to actually
have the assurance
that we know what we own.
DAVID "CACHE"
MCWHERTER: Great story.
And now you guys can
do the same thing.
So another thing that
Google likes to do,
Subhash, is that
pretty much everything
that we run in
production tends to go
through a secure-- not a secure,
but a source code review--
and then gets committed to
our source control system.
And then from there,
only from there
does it get pushed
to production.
And previously, before
we had all the APIs
we now have from Iam, it was
actually kind of a little bit
hard.
We couldn't actually
ensure that.
All the policy updates
had to be done by hand.
But now we have a way of
programmatically managing
ACLs and other things.
So we can actually
write tooling that
sucks from our source
control system,
scans all the
projects to make sure
that they actually
look as we think
they should be configured.
And then if they're
not, we alert
or we can even use
organizational level powers
to just go and set
them as we need.
SUBHASH SANKURATRIPATI:
Sounds cool.
So we actually do something
very similar for one part
of our ACLs.
Because we're not Google,
we don't have access
to those internal APIs.
But you know, what would be
cool is if you could actually
open source some of that--
DAVID "CACHE" MCWHERTER:
That's a great idea.
And somebody at Google
has already had that idea.
And there's already working on
getting it through the process
out the door to open source it.
And so soon, we'll share
all that code with you.
SUBHASH SANKURATRIPATI: Cool.
Looking forward to using it.
DAVID "CACHE" MCWHERTER: Rae?
Can we turn it back over to you?
Thanks, Ryan, by the way.
It's awesome.
RAE WANG: [INAUDIBLE].
So I hope you've
enjoyed this talk.
Everything we've showed
you in this chart
are now available
to you and our team,
we're really excited to see what
you can do with these tools.
So if you want to get in touch,
send us feedback, thoughts,
feature [INAUDIBLE],
this is how to email us.
You can also come to
the infrastructure booth
to chat even more about Iam.
Thank you.